好虽然我们即将迎来
连续性的都是四个交易日
四个交易日放假固然开心
但是科技的脚步没有停下来
这礼拜就有台积电的OIP论坛
还有Meta也会有它的开发者大会
有很多的新产品新科技
陆陆续续都要把它拿出来讲了
所以我们看到今天盘面上
AI股科技股是相对强势的
那你会觉得联电
这个其实非常多散户的希望
慢慢的回到比较强势的位阶了
將會帶動連家軍做一番的補漲
再來的話很多人對選股覺得很難
但是證交所有一個普遇指數
裡面300多家
有傳產也有電子重點在
現在還很低調
未來會幫你賺錢
對 因為第三季快要寂寞
所以連電連家軍有集團作帳
那第四季我覺得大家可以去關注一下
有一些比較沒有被發現到的
在第四季資金行李回流之後
我覺得就有機會做一些發動的動作
所以首先我們來看一下
這禮拜相關的大事情
明天有全球的記憶體峰會
大家可以關注一下
明天記憶體股票會有一些
帶量的反彈
9月23號是這個禮拜的重頭戲
台經的OIP論壇
相關的14奈米 16奈米到先進製成的3DIC
CPU 細光子等等的
其實很多這些股票
可能今天都還沒有發動
也許我覺得在禮拜三 禮拜四這兩天
都可以關注到這些
有題材性的股票
有沒有隨著論壇的利多
隨便發動的情況
另外禮拜三的晚上
有META的開發大會
我覺得這個重頭戲應該還是在 AI 演進相關的
在禮拜天大摩又出了一個報告
他說全球 AI 半導體需求會快速的成長
看好了23檔的股票
那重頭戲在什麼
他說雖然在 2028 年資本支出會放緩
那 2026 2027 年大幅度的成長
所以還是跟大家講
你要把握現在到明年上半年
我覺得對台股來講是一個非常好的利多窗口
那半導體的部分它的延續性會比較好
到2030年為止相關的年幅成長率
還達到30個百分點
那對台股來講
只要跟著半導力有關的
我覺得都有機會在未來幾年
維持非常好的成長性
好 那大家來看它今天的兩個主角
那聯邦克當然對台股來講非常重要
它是台灣第二大的全資股
那也是IC設計的精神指標
當它創造率新高的時候
整個IC設計整個股性就會活潑起來了
所以今天股價來到5035的歷史新高
很可怕 我記得今年年初看到它
才一千多塊
對 那有多次的利多題材
你發現聯發科很特別
它這個大牛皮的股票
都是用跳空漲停在跳的
在表態
對 所以我覺得今年聯發科
真的有一個比較不一樣的題材
那另外也可以看到聯電
聯電這個波段以來
其實這個跌
185跌到102也跌得滿深的
那最近我覺得也隨著它的業績
隨著它的一個漲價題材
產能利用率跟相關的
新事業的佈局
股價現在是佔到所有捐之上
以這樣的形態來看的話
這個底型完成之後
我覺得是有機會挑戰
今年創下一個波段的高點
那如果這兩家都能夠往上創高的話
對他們集團的股票
我覺得會有正面的帶動
因為怎麼這樣講
就是說聯發科它所代表的是
台灣的IC設計西智財
那當它拉到一個波段新高之後
大家第一個想到
整個西智財啊
IC設計會有一個比價
消費本益比拉高的空間
第二個就是
它旗下的一些小經濟們
今年其實都很悶
你看亞信 達發 九陽 清新科
唯一比較活潑是九陽
對 但其他都很悶
就是以前過往如果你把今年排除的話過往三年到五年之內大家都看他下面的小星期沒有來看聯發科因為聯發科大部分時間就是一個橫降盤整那今年不一樣
母公司這個發光發熱
但子公司相關的小星期們
反而比較暗淡無光
但我覺得來到第四季的話
如果聯發科居為是這麼強勢的話
旗下的一些水相關的
比較小型的股票
也可以特別來看待
那聯電集團
但每一次到了這個第四季
往往有大家期待的作賬行情
由於他的一個旗下的一些小公司們
都比較活潑一點
所以我覺得目前來看
都可以把這些所謂的
兩家聯發科跟聯電
他相關的集團股
在接下來的行情當中
列為你可以特別參考的股票
那我們來跟大家講
有哪一些可以特別關注的
好 今天漲停板的系統啊
對 那系統大家應該要記得
疫情的時候他變成聯電的這個新歡
也就是說這個集團的董事長
跳下來當他的董事長
所以那時候有非常多的資源依託在系統的身上
那經過這幾年的一個整理
大家還是可以發現到
它事業體慢慢在改善了
今天好不容易出了一個稍微帶量的攻擊
站到季線之上
那我們會講說
這樣的股票
既然已經完成了底型突破之後
大家就可以抓這個季線的關卡
如果有拉回到季線附近
我就是可以做一個縫低承接的
一般來講
第四季對I7代然來講
就會比較活潑一些
那另外可以看到這個是
應該也算是聯發科比較輕的兒子叫達發
當年他掛牌之後股價一度破發
聯發科還挹注資金
去職業實施庫長股
把股價拉升上來
達發在聯發科企管裡面
負責的是所謂的無線網路通訊
所以我覺得對於接下來
在所謂的相關手機市場
或未來的邊緣運算AI當中
他應該都有一席之地
所以目前股價現行
他剛好佔到所有均衍之上
而且曾經多放一個排列
連續兩天大量外資戰案買發
那營收表現也維持一個比較量的成長
上半年大概賺10塊錢
所以目前的本益比我覺得算是合理
所以我覺得這兩檔公司就變成說
如果大家覺得第一次季有集團作詐
有IC設計題材的話
都可以特別的留意
那當然大家會覺得說
IC設計股票可能活潑性太高了
如果我們要找一些比較安穩的標的的話
有沒有一些相關可以參考的一個東西
那剛好證交所在這幾年
發了一個普遇指數
那簡單幫大家介紹一下
什麼叫樸易指數
它選果我覺得蠻特別的
第一個它重視什麼
殖利率在
台股排行前50%
第二個它重視的是公司的治理
大概有59%的成分股
是公司治理評鑑前50%
另外也注意到台灣的永續評鑑
在A級以上
國外的不管是所謂主權基金
或說一些比較大型的ETF
很重視這兩個評鑑
當評鑑在高的時候
才可以納入它相關的成分股
因為全球很重視ESG的一個
永續經營
所以我覺得對於投資朋友來講的話
你選這樣的股票
第一個就是
它相對的財務數字很好
也能夠成為可能部分
國外外資能夠首選的標的
所以以這樣的情況
我們跟大家簡單去做個總結
你選普遺指數
它相對是能夠獲利
但比較不會炒作的公司
那也能夠耐震抗疊
而且它對一個產業的部分
分散度是比較好的
而且它會把一些像什麼
自由流通周轉率
成交股數等等的
前10%的公司先把它排除掉
因為他不希望說
我的指數當中
有一些股票是超漲超跌
對一些長期投資人來講
會造成一定的困擾
以他這個發行以來
他的一個相關的追蹤指數的表現大概從2007年到今年的上半年為止累積報酬率是609.95%算是不錯的那重點在於說當遇到行情波動大的時候
它相對都比較能夠抵禦波動
因為剛剛看到
它選擇有的是殖利率好的
而且要永續經營的
也等於說
在大盤遇到一些重挫
或是波動的時候
它應該要抗震
對 除了剛剛講的選股特性以外
你可以發現它分散度也很好
你看它在這個
新出來的一個成分股當中
電子產業佔比大概是51.36
其他傳染人家金融大概是一半
所以基本上電子金融各半
也代表說當你看到
9月份台股金融值數一直衝高的時候
它表現就特別的好
那另外在大中小的一個分散
跟權重的分散
我覺得在相關值數當中
算是做得比較好的一個
重點的指數
那我們再來看一下
它的一個成分股
大家會覺得說
那這指數會不會就是
有一點點大家可能
關注度沒那麼高
但我們講說
以它的選股邏輯來看的話
當有一些優質的股票
也會成為其他ETF鎖定的標的
我們來看一下
普利指數的成分股
目前有主被動ETF鎖定的
像當中一檔到五檔有123檔都持有它
然後有20檔ETF同時鎖定11檔的股票
所以代表它不是完全就是
好像大家覺得可能是這種
被隱藏的珍珠
沒有低調那麼離譜
對 其實蠻多已經被大家發現到了
所以我覺得這個情況裡面也代表說
你可以透過它的成分股當中
去挑到好的股票
那我们大家整理出来
就是说刚刚提到的
在331档当中
有195档是位于公司
自己的前50个百分点
那21档是位于前50个百分点
所以刚刚提到的嘛
就是说你投资除了
重视绩效以外
我觉得大家对于公司
自己的肯定
也是大家投资上面
可以考虑的
因为一般来讲
公司是一个好的公司
代表他们公司经营的状况
也会比较良好
所以以这样的情况来
选股的话也代表说
你选这个指数投资的成分股
可以兼顧到
對於永續投資
大家付出一點的心力
好 那來看一下
它的前十大成分股當中
第一大家是統一
你可以看到
它有這些股票
但大家都耳熟能詳
那這樣的情況大家會覺得說
那這個指數會不會相對來看
就比較穩健一些比較溫
對 看起來是比較抗跌保守的組合
會不會有這個問題
對 那我們來看一下
其實這當中有蠻多股票
是最近非常強勢的
來看一下
它的成分股當中
你看 台灣大創立子新高
台灣大創立時新高的是不是
他跟金城的換股
讓金城也創下新高
對 我們講說
其實對電信三雄來講
但一直是穩健的標的
大凡國家創選新高
我覺得他們創高也是合理的
另外一檔大概非常熱門
是中砂
也跟禮拜三的台建論壇有關
股價現在已經來到916塊了
可能是新的千元股的一個
候選人了
對 它的晚漢轉強的話
我覺得對相關的半導體材料來講
我覺得都會有一些比較大的想像空間
那接下來另外一檔快要創高的是技嘉
技嘉也是大家覺得悶很久的股票
但不知不覺的
隨著最近整個AI股的一個重新轉強
它股價也快要挑戰今年以來的一個新高
所以我覺得在這樣的情況當中
就可以發現到
雖然樸宜指數大家覺得好像有聽過
但是我覺得當中選的很多股票
是具備代表性的
所以我覺得現行或說
整個所謂的架構上面
有越轉越走越強的一個跡象
那再跟大家講就是說
在這樣的情況裡面
有沒有一些可能是大家
可以特別在關注的一些相關個股
同樣是譜越指數當中的一個
重要成分股
那首先我們來看到這個工業電腦的這個股王 炎華那炎華股價前波穿到日子也很高之後我覺得這個時間點大家可以發現到量能量都還沒有出來
所以代表我覺得這家公司
跟普遺指數的一個特性一樣非常穩健
我覺得股價部分
只要它這個月線的關卡能夠守穩的話
隨著第四季的行情
我覺得是有創高的空間
因為我們可以看到
它有33檔的主被動ETF都持有它
然後今年它的配息
去年配的分數是11.2
然後永續跟自己分數拿到三個A的等級
在公司自己平均是前五個百分點
所以它一直以來是台灣我覺得是非常典範的一家公司
那你可以看到今年的這個EPS
上半年就已經賺了9.05元
跟去年比較起來
今年創新高應該是沒有任何的問題
大家可能都會說它是好公司
其實好公司是可以量化的
永續與智理拿到三個A
智理評鑑是全台股的前5%
好公司就這樣定義了嗎
同樣是樸育指數的成分股
育金光
還滿讓人意外的
但它的獲利跟本益比之前還滿合理的
因為之前在沒有這一段以前
它大概就是400塊到600塊
所以有非常多的主被動ETF持有它
很多高股息都有它
那當然如果有它
你可能要小心一下
11月份很多可能會被踢除
所以對於籌碼來講
會有一定的影響的情況
但是因為現在還在9月份
所以我覺得可能大家短樣
不用擔心這個問題
但最少以這個情況來看
它這個波段漲勢
漲得非常兇
那這個波段修正下來之後
大概在月線附近
呈現一個低檔的支撐
那我們會跟大家講
玉晶光彈
第一件事情
它本身是蘋果的題材
所以我們大致上可以看到
過去這幾年的EPS
上半年都是賺很少
對 但第三季
第四季它的業績爆發期
所以今年的上半已經賺了13.99
我覺得下半年來看
如果維持去年的水準
它今年的獲利會超越去年
所以有機會去挑戰可能2024年相對的歷史新高
如果股價歷史新高搭配業績歷史新高的話
我覺得它的股價的一個穩定度會變得更高
如果普遇指數都能夠選出這樣的股票的話
我覺得在這種相對低檔比較乏人問津的時候
反正你可以特別關注到指數成分股當中
有沒有一些最近業績上來了
股價現行變好
甚至有ETF開始鎖定的標的
那看到另外一檔股票
跟航運有關
航運啊
好 育民這個
所謂的散裝航運
對 那散裝航運
當然大家可以關注到
最近的所謂運價指數也慢慢上來
那中東的局勢還是相當的緊張
那育民同樣也是高股
ETF喜歡的一個標的
那我覺得以今年的獲利其實非常好
你可以看到
它的不管是在配息的成績
等等的一個治理
我覺得都維持在台股的
相對好的公司當中
那今年上半已經賺了3.5億元了
跟過去這幾年相比
其實今年我覺得輕輕鬆
有機會創造率是新高
所以今年創高代表明年
也會維持一個高配息
那以目前的運價指數來看
我覺得都可以特別的留意
那像這種股票
你可以看到它整理上
它一些基本面
都是可以透過普遇指數的
這樣選股方式
提前幫你張羅選到當中
我覺得可能在低位間
你沒有注意到的時候
我覺得可以透過它的成分股
去選到好的標的
好 因為可能大家會覺得
大AI時代
講來講去都是AI股
可是普玉指數它竟然是未來有機會發酵
或是長期公司治理非常厲害的公司
它的傳產比例也不低
所以大家如果想要做好的資產配置
應該去裡面挖寶
對啊
好 這邊非常謝謝漢偉哥